bonjour david alors on vient de le dire
vous êtes à bruxelles qu est ce qui se
passe actuellement
oui alors comme on a pu le suivre toute
la journée les convoyeurs de la liberté
se sont rassemblés une première fois ce
matin à villepinte pour ensuite prendre
la direction de l'aéroport de
lille-lesquin
alors certains sont allés à l'aéroport
et d'autres sont venus directement à
bruxelles par peur de se faire stopper à
la frontière belge 1 par les forces de
l'ordre c'est ce qui s'est passé par
exemple ce matin pour certains
convoyeurs qui étaient à fontainebleau
en tout cas bruxelles se prépare à
accueillir à cette manifestation on a pu
apercevoir dans la ville et des canons à
eau disposés un peu partout de nombreux
camions de gendarmes et policiers et
puis les panneaux de signalisation
également qui est prêt vienne de fortes
perturbations de la circulation dès
demain après voir ici même à bruxelles
malgré les heures et à les tensions
qu'il ya pu y avoir hier lors de la
mobilisation à paris et bien elle les
convoyeurs de la liberté sont toujours
aussi motivés aussi déterminé ils
réclament la fin du pass vaccinale et
surtout la fin des restrictions
sanitaires ils manifestent ils se
mobilisent pour garder leurs droits
fondamentaux et leurs libertés
fondamentales depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire il estime que tous les
gouvernements européens imposent des
restrictions qui sont est liberticide ou
cette convergence européenne à bruxelles
bruxelles qui est le symbole même un
dieu de l'europe puisque le parlement
européen se trouve ici je vous propose
d'écouter quelques uns des convoyeurs de
liberté qu'on a pu interroger ce matin
sur le parking de ville pas tu sais quel
quand même assez remarquable c'est que
dans le pays des droits de l'homme la
répression et la plus sauvage 1 puisque
depuis les gilet jaune ne savons très
bien que ce gouvernement de macron
n'hésitent pas à tirer sur des gens
désarmés pacifique et s'ils nous allons
à bruxelles et que comme tout le monde
sait il est le président de l'europe
nous nous attendons à la même chose mais
là pour la liberté on est là pour nos
enfants pour nous pour nous mais pour
nous le vieux pour aussi pouvoir d'achat
qui en train de dégringoler depuis
quelques mois et ceci pour montrer notre
mécontentement du gouvernement qu'elles
soient français ou européens qui nous
mène une politique sanitaire désastreuse
donc voilà on n'est pas anti vaccins on
est contre les mesures sanitaires et on
va dire la milda à côté d'une certaine
population qui refuse de se plier au
gouvernement et à l'idéologie sanitaires
tels ras-le-bol de tous les citoyens je
vous dise at war français la belge c'est
tout le monde en a vraiment ras le bol
et on n'est pas écouté et regardé
comment on ne répond on y répond par une
présence policière par des fourgons de
l'armée par des blindés alors que nous
on en vient avec nos voitures
personnelles on met de l'argent dans nos
voitures et on est reçu comme de la
merde voilà pour éviter d'éveiller tout
soupçon de la part de la police et bien
le convoi de la liberté c'est un peu
dispatcher 1 l'objectif pour eux est
d'arriver en de manière morcelée à la
frontière belge afin de ne pas attirer
l'attention sur eux ce qu'on a pu
remarquer sur la route est bien c'est
que sur les aires d'autoroutes et bien
elle et policiers belges opérait à des
contrôles un dell des contrôles de
véhicules pour pourvoir lors leurs
véritables intentions quant à leur
rentrée en belgique qui était moine donc
d'une d'une tension palpable 1 à la
veille d'une manifestation qui s'annonce
historique
merci à david pour toutes ces précisions